just like any soccer team Germany's top
politicians made some quick lineup
changes before the main event Chancellor
Angela Merkel president your home calc
and interior minister Thomas de Murcia
were all on hand to greet Germany's
World Cup winners and award them the
country's higher sporting accolade the
silver laurel leaf that's feelin's in
deutschland I love everyone back in
Germany felt like they were world
champions that day rescue a nostalgia
what a strong teams in patch what a
likeable athletic and all-around
exciting team guys send of mine shaft
there was a degree of deja vu the
national soccer team won the award after
coming third in 2010 now thanks to mario
gotze's deciding goal in Brazil they're
back as winners Phillip onion many of
you have been here before nice to me
esta muy da but this time we're back
here with the world cup making the day
even more special it was our generation
our team that's what makes this so
amazing that special feeling wasn't lost
on the German president yo him gulp
looked every bit the world champion as
he posed with the trophy